after that happened funeral after
funeral after funeral is just non-stop
and I you know I ended up just getting
numb to it you know get your mental
health right try to channel that energy
into something that's positive that's
gonna you know get you out of the
situation that you're in that was my
whole thing like music was always the
goal of of just okay this is going to be
my vehicle that gets me out of this area
and that changes my life you know what
I'm saying so you know you just gotta
find and all of us we got hidden talents
people don't like to explore them or
they may feel like oh it's corny people
may talk about me like nah it comes with
what's naturally good to you it's there
for a reason you know I'm saying God
ain't put it in your put it in you if it
wasn't supposed to be like that so don't
be afraid to explore what makes you
great no matter what nobody says yeah
man you don't never know where God's
gonna take you and that's why I like to
tell myself every day like have
unwavering Faith you feel me and I'm
just gonna let
let them take me where he's supposed to
take me you got